Copenhagen was not as successful as we
all would have expected but it was
substantive progress and remember it's
the first time when we have commitments
by the United States the policy
commitments by India and by China
specific commitments by the EU in terms
of targets a renewed strength and
commitment by Japan and large emerging
countries in Latin America like Brazil
Mexico both have made their own
independent commitments and targeting so
there is a lot of progress what happened
in Copenhagen is we picked up part of
these of these advances we now have to
move to a more specific more targeted
and also more binding type of agreement
people expect that I think we're going
to be working towards that in cop16 in
Mexico but also from here to cop 16 it's
almost a year that we have to take
advantage of in order to deal with both
the technicalities as well as a mattress
of financing the whole deal can make a
break in terms of whether there is a
viable financing package there are ways
in which one can put a viable financing
package together there is the political
world there is the awareness and I think
even in the largest emerging economies
there is not only the awareness but
there's also the conviction that they
have to do things for their own benefit
as well as for the responsibility they
have a visa V the rest of the world